dominique jean chertier bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes le
président du pôle emploi dont vous allez
nous rappeler ce que c'est que le pôle
emploi à l'origine donc c'est le
rassemblement de deux entités qui traite
du problème des chômeurs que le
président de la république souhaitait
rassembler donc c'était un des ses
engagements de campagne électorale et en
même temps c'était un engagement d'avant
la crise puisque avant la crise tout le
monde pensait et la situation semblait
s'y conformer que le chômage allait
reculer le chômage d'ailleurs était en
train de reculer donc on était dans une
logique les dires managériale classique
on rassemble les efforts on essaie de le
gérer cela tout cela de façon plus
efficace
on met en place le pôle emploi et puis
la crise est arrivée donc d'abord voilà
qu'est ce que ça change
l'arrivée de cette crise et de ce nombre
incalculable de chômeurs est ce que le
pôle emploi répond aussi bien à la crise
qu'il était censé répondre à une
situation en voie d'amélioration sur le
plan du chômage mais peut-être faut-il
d'abord rappeler ce que sait comment ça
fonctionne elle est là la france était
dans une situation assez atypique ayant
d'un côté un organisme qui est indemnisé
et de l'autre côté un organisme qui
plaçait l'organisme qui indemnise
c'était l'unedic et les assedic est
l'organisme qui plaçait c'est l anpe
le premier créé en 58 deuxième dent
les années en fin des années soixante
soixante cette situation ont quitté le
fruit de l'histoire mais dont on voyait
bien qu'en fait elle crée des
difficultés non pas dans le
fonctionnement normal mais pour les
demandeurs d'emploi qui perdent le lui
un contractuel unis qu'ils ont avec un
employeur qui tout d'un coup se
retrouvent ayants droit et puis qu'ils
vont acquérir des droits évoquèrent des
droits c'est déjà pas facile mais quand
il faut aller le faire dans différents
organismes dont on ne voit pas très bien
la différence
effectivement le temps était venu de
rassembler ces deux activités
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire et parce qu'ils
vont en bout de chaîne on constate du
point de vue de ceux qui demandent
l'exercice de leurs droits donc du point
de vue des chômeurs faut qu'on constate
une amélioration et la balle en compte
heureusement bassa a percuté une
situation économique que personne
n'avait prévu puisque je rappelle qu'il
y a un an
rares étaient les économistes les
prévisionnistes de tout genre qui
pouvait imaginer que retrouverait dans
une situation où au début de cette année
2009 on a eu trois mille demandeurs
d'emploi de plus par jour
s'inscrivant à pôle emploi trois mille
par jour
alors on est un rythme qui s'est un peu
atténuée mais je suis moi si on était au
mois d'avril encore mars avril un rythme
de deux mille demandeurs d'emploi de
plus par jour voilà alors
est ce qu'il fallait faire cette fusion
dans cette circonstance
d'abord on n'avait pas le choix la
fusion était lancée la deuxième chose
c'est effectivement moi ce que j'ai pu
constater sur le terrain c'est que là où
ça fonctionne bien il ya beaucoup
d'endroits où ça fonctionne bien c'est
plutôt mieux pour les demandeurs
d'emploi et si globalement je me
rapporte à une situation que j'ai vécu
moi dans le début des années 90 en tant
que patron des assedic et de l'unedic
et bien en fait on l'oublié mais au
début des années 90 on était dans des
situations où il y avait des retards
considérables sur l'indemnisation des
demandeurs d'emploi et où il y avait
également des dossiers en instance qu'on
appelle les deux centres étaient donc et
qui étaient en nombre beaucoup plus
important que ce qu'on a connu une
longue période où il y avait eu
d'ailleurs aussi un pic de chômage
puisque l'année 92 93 est une année de
presque deux records d'ailleurs encore
qui sera peut-être dépassé par les
circonstances actuelles mais donc une
année de très très fortes explosions
bachelot ce sont des années qu'on peut
en termes d'activité comparer et donc la
situation est plutôt
- mauvaise paix celle qu'on a connue à
l'époque alors comment ça fonctionne
vous vous êtes président du pôle emploi
donc il ya un directeur général qui met
en place voilà les actions de pas loin
de 50 mille personnes alors
effectivement il y à une dissociation
entre un organe qui est un organe
d'impulsion et de contrôle qui est le
conseil d'administration qui est un
organe composé à la fois de
représentants de l'état de représentants
des partenaires sociaux patronat et
syndicats et de personnalités qualifiées
ainsi que d'une personne qui représente
les collectivités territoriales donc
c'est un ensemble assez complexe qu'il
faut faire foisonner ça vous présidez
vous masser et il y a un directeur
général avec une dérision général qui
pilote l'ensemble des activités
opérationnelles de des 45000 personnes
qui composent pôle emploi et qui sont
donc au contact des contacts des
demandeurs d'emploi sur le terrain alors
le problème c'est que cette réforme est
assez contesté aujourd'hui notamment
parce qu'ils siègent puisque vous avez
dit que les partenaires sociaux siéger
au sein de votre conseil
d'administration notamment par les
partenaires sociaux alors que répondre à
ceux qui globalement pense que c'est
moins efficace ou pas assez encore
efficace comme dispositif moi je
comprendrai qu'elle fait partie de ce
qu'il pense que ça n'est pas encore
assez efficace mais compte tenu de la
situation maintenant bon mais toi parce
qu'ils étaient contre la création de
l'unedic en 58 contre elle a créé à cela
une paix en 67 et qui est en bonne
logique sont contre la fusion des deux
mais mise à part cette situation qui est
bon une position politique respectable
mais qu en aucun cas ne répond à la
nécessité pour les demandeurs d'emploi
d'être bien traité
je pense que
actuellement nous avons fait un certain
nombre de choses mais que nous avons
beaucoup de progrès à faire
ces progrès dans quel dans quel domaine
vaudois devait vous progressez dans ce
que nous avons fait déjà c'est que nous
avons réduit le nombre de dossiers en
instance et globalement actuellement
nous avons autour de 50 mille dossiers
en instance qu'il représente deux jours
de traitement est vraiment ça c'est un
progrès considérable qui a été fait par
tous les actifs sur le terrain c'est que
depuis le mois de janvier les choses se
sont améliorées de ce point de vue là de
plus un nombre d'emplois quand il
s'adresse à pôle emploi pour avoir un
rendez vous il faut cinq jours à peu
près et ce qui veut dire qu on l à peu
près nom du domaine du raisonnable
c'est le point le plus sensible ça parce
qu'on sur les radios on entend souvent
atone et on va faire l'expérience alors
on téléphone ont décrit ce qu'il est
mais on est renvoyé de ce qui ne marche
pas effectivement c'est en termes
d'accessibilité
c'est le système du 39 49 qui s'est
améliorée mais qui est loin d'être
parfait 39 pas encore 9 saint point
d'accès unique par téléphone mais
effectivement on se rend compte qu'il
n'est pas au niveau d'efficacité qu'on
souhaiterait là il faut qu'on fasse des
progrès deuxièmement effectivement on a
constaté que il entraîne des coûts pour
les demandeurs d'emploi et là il faut le
résoudre
alors il ya eu des négociations avec les
opérateurs qui font que ce coût a baissé
on va voir au niveau du conseil
d'administration comment on peut pour
les demandeurs d'emploi les plus démunis
avoir des c'est ce qu'indique
cessibilité par carte prépayée et c'est
ça on va le regarder mais globalement il
faut que ce système qui est en fait un
principe très simple c'est à dire avoir
un accès unique un service public que ce
serait cet axe est l'unique qui
fonctionne bien et tout cela donc vous
le disiez travers dans un contexte
voilà de montée du chômage assez assez
spectaculaire est donc d'autant plus
difficile j'imagine à traiter pour un
service public en voie de constitution
parce que c'est pas simple de rapprocher
c'est pas simple dans la vie des
entreprises privées de rapprocher une
entreprise avec une autre mais dans la
vie des services publics idem je veux
dire c'est chacun a sa culture chacun a
son mode de fonctionnement ainsi de
suite effectivement je chaque entreprise
qui a fusionné avec une autre c'est à
quel point c'est difficile et combien d
années après en garde les traces des
cultures antérieur mais au-delà de cet
aspect il y avait en plus des différents
statuts qui a imposé des consultations
nombreuses avec les organisations
représentatives du personnel ont tous
assez compliqué mais sur sept sur cette
fusion
on voit très bien qu'elle se met en
oeuvre un moment où la situation du
chômage est déjà très dégradées mais où
en plus les offres d'emploi soit en
diminution par rapport à l'année passée
et quand un demandeur d'emploi bien
s'adresser à pôle emploi
quand il s'adresse à pôle emploi c'est
pour avoir une réponse en terme de
proposition et dès lors que non pas du
fait de pôle emploi mais du fait de la
situation économique
le nombre d'offres d'emploi qu'on peut
présenter aux demandeurs d'emploi est en
diminution
effectivement le demandeur d'emploi en
bonne logique il a plus de cette
situation non pas à la crise en général
mais à l'organisme qu'il a en face de
lui et c'est tout à fait humain et on
voit très bien que si la situation
économique
même avec un niveau de chômage très
élevé était meilleur en termes de
propositions d'emploi bien entendu
l'image même de pôle emploi sera
améliorée est ce qui vous est ce que
vous avez néanmoins des marges de
manoeuvre dans la relation entre pôle
emploi et les entreprises du made in que
ça se joue
plus près de chaque réalité locale oui
alors il faut savoir reconnaître ses
torts et dans la situation qu'on a connu
en janvier février qui était une
situation serait véritablement très
tendues pour ne pas dire plus on s'est
concentré sur les activités
d'inscription et d'indemnisation ce qui
était le plus urgent est du même coup on
a eu tendance à moins mettre la pression
sur l'activité de recherche d'offres
d'emploi auprès des employeurs il faut
que ce contact soit rétabli rapidement
avec les l'entreprise parce que c'est
pas pour l'emploi qui donne des emplois
ordonnée machinalement augmentant les
effectifs mais ce sont les entreprises
et les entreprises faut qu'on aille
chercher les offres d'emploi auprès des
entreprises
sur un autre plan donc on est dans un
contexte où tout le monde est touché
tous les pays sont touchés et en même
temps approche les élections européennes
donc est-ce qu'à vos yeux qui regardait
ses problèmes d'emploi depuis un certain
temps déjà
l'ascap non mais ça vous donne en même
temps une vision un recul sur une sur
une plus longue période
est ce que il y a à vos yeux quelque
chose qui serait à faire au niveau de
l'union européenne en matière d'emplois
qui seraient de nature à améliorer le
fonctionnement de nos systèmes et donc
améliorer au bout de la route le feu la
situation faite aux chômeurs ou bien
est-ce que définitivement c'est quelque
chose qui doit rester j'allais dire
lequel nationale votre votre question et
est complexe puisque on a tendance à
considérer que l'emploi est d'abord une
question locale voire même infra locales
au terme de hausse ans de bassin
d'emploi
effectivement
les réponses on les voit immédiatement
sur une situation géographique très
limité bon ceci étant on sait très bien
que ni à des régions qui sont plus
affectées que d'autres et que les
notions de mobilité je ne parle même pas
de mobilité européenne mobilité
infranational sont des réalités qui va
ça va falloir traiter parce que des
bassins d'emploi sont sinistrées
d'autres par contre sont en situation
quasiment le plein de plein emploi
je pense que au delà des questions
marginales que sont les régions
frontalières frontalières où
effectivement là l'europe peut jouer un
rôle mais le joue déjà
il y as probablement au niveau européen
parce que le problème qu'on rencontre en
france on le rencontre aussi en europe
c'est une question d'adaptation de la
main-d'oeuvre aux besoins des
entreprises
il ya probablement des grands programmes
de formation ou des aides à la formation
qui peuvent être conçus au delà même de
la dimension nationale parce que pour le
moment tout ce qui est mouvement
d'industrie de déplacement d'industrie
est perçu comme l'abomination de la
désolation c'est à dire on transporte
une industrie d'ici à là avec le fameux
exemple utilisé par nicolas sarkozy sur
la tchéquie il y a provoqué des tensions
que lancé entre les deux pays alors que
si une organisation meilleur du
territoire européen pourrait peut-être
facilité les choses
à condition que voilà des déplacements
puisse être possible vous organisez ou
améliorés dans un territoire où l'on est
censé circuler librement dans une
situation de crise on a toujours
tendance à voir surgir les égoïsmes
nationaux voire même territoriaux c'est
tout à fait tout à fait humain et dans
le même temps ne pas voir tout ce que
l'europe l'ouverture du marché européen
a apporté comme développement économique
donc il faudra un jour ou l'autre
concilier ces deux aspects l'aspect
social et l'aspect heureux l aspect
économique sur le plan européen
autre sujet qui vous concerne donc là
nous étions sur le pôle emploi que vous
que vous présidez que vous pilotez avec
les les difficultés que vous venez de
nous évoquer vous aviez été chargé par
le président de la république d'une
mission de réflexion pour suivi d'un
rapport que vous que vous lui avez remis
sur la réforme éventuelle d'une
institution peu connu dans la république
qui est le conseil économique et social
conseil économique et social c'est une
assemblée de membres désignés qui
représente donc la société civile et qui
est placé auprès du premier ministre
auprès du gouvernement
alors qu'est-ce que vous ai découvert
dans ce rapport
faut-il réformer ce type d'assemblée
pour quoi faire et comment conseils d'un
ami cas social est effectivement peu
connu trop peu connu des français
quelquefois trop peu connue de la
puissance publique exécutive aussi et
c'est la troisième assemblée de la
république française alors c'est une
assemblée qui est censé représenter la
société civile
ce que cela représente quand on regarde
il ya par exemple les organisations
syndicales et patronales sont très
fortement représentés les organisations
patronales et syndicales sont
représentés mais sans prétendre est une
image fidèle de l'aide de la société je
pense qu'une assemblée comme le conseil
économique et social doit être plus
proche de la représentation de la
société civile qu'elle ne l'est
actuellement
en d'autres termes par exemple
non la présentation il ya cette chose si
on regarde la composition de la société
civile on voit que le le poids du
salariat a augmenté par rapport à ce
qu'il était dans les années 50
or il n'a pas à augmenter à due
proportion le poids des petites
entreprises et de l'artisanat a augmenté
il n'a pas augmenté au sein d'une
présentation
ce n'est pas faire offense au monde
agricole que de dire que ils ont une
représentation qui correspond à peu près
à ce qu'on trouvait dans la france des
années 60 et pas ceux qu'on trouve dans
la france des années 2010 ça c'est une
grande tradition nationale assure
représentation d'été comptablement
probablement milieu agricole et donc il
y a une problématique de composition il
y a ensuite une problématique qui touche
à la répartition hommes-femmes
c'est une assemblée comme vous le disait
fort justement désigné et s'agissant
d'une assemblée désignée il n'y a aucune
raison de ne pas imposer une
représentation une répartition
hommes-femmes qui correspond à la
réalité de la population active la
moitié de la donc la parité devrait
s'appliquer la peau et il devrait
s'appliquer
on est loin et on en est très loin et
s'agissant d'une assemblée dit du
premier mot il paraîtrait normal que le
nombre de mandats dans leur succession
soit limité à deux c'est quoi une
assemblée dit du premier mot ben c'est
d'une assemblée qui débat de tous les
thèmes sans que sa nécessité de
traduction législative mais ça permet à
l'ensemble des corps intermédiaires de
s'exprimer sur différents sujets qu'ils
soient des sujets sociaux économiques
environnementaux et éthiques
également et ça permet d'éclairer le
pouvoir exécutif et le pouvoir
législatif prenons l'exemple du travail
dominical c'est un sujet qui a
particulièrement intéressé
voilà un sujet qui a été débattue au
sein du conseil économique et social
personne n'a entendu parler et
malheureusement personne n'a entendu pas
à me parler d'un débat qui est un débat
riche qui a permis à toutes les parties
de s'exprimer sans enjeu immédiat mais
qui devrait de mon point de vue en tout
cas inscrire un débat parlementaire ou
une décision exécutive voila l'exemple
type de choses où le conseil économique
et social travail et travaille
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup d'application
mais où il n'y a malheureusement pas une
prise en compte insuffisante de ces
débats et de ces travaux ensuite dans
l'élaboration législatives ou dans les
décisions de toute nature prises par le
groupe pour revenir d'un mot sur la
représentation puisqu'on cherchari
représenter la société civile
et puis après évidemment le problème
c'est de savoir si ça sert à quelque
chose mais ça c'est aux politiques d'en
décider s'étaient ils peuvent très bien
faire fun mais pour en revenir à la
représentation on sait que le président
de la république lui souhaitait dans
l'élargissement de cette représentation
vous vous évoquiez la parité et les
femmes lui avait livré d'introduire des
représentants des religions ès qualité
alors est ce que ça faisait partie de
vos conclusions à vous et comment vous
voyez ce problème c'est celle pour
beaucoup c'est délicat dans une
institution laïque enfin dans des
institutions laïques comme les nôtres
alors ça c'est un point est
effectivement sur lequel j'ai travaillé
et à cette occasion elle fait rencontrer
l'ensemble des intéressés c'est à dire
les représentants des grands cultes
musulmans protestants catholiques et
juifs et
il rencontre également les représentants
de ce qu'on appelle le mouvement
philosophique c'est à dire les francs
maçons
d'ailleurs j'étais extrêmement intéressé
par la puissance analyse de ces
différents courants sur les évolutions
sociétales et j'ai pensé effectivement
qu'elle pouvait être d'un apport très
intéressante
beaucoup de questions qui touchent la
société
pour autant faut-il les considérer comme
représentants de la société civile et je
ne le pense pas c'est pour ça que j'ai
proposé un dispositif qui associe ces
différents courants de pensée courants
philosophiques ou religieux à
l'élaboration d'un certain nombre de
réflexions et il faudrait que vous
proposez que la loi prévoit que sur
différents sujets éthiques
eh bien les mouvements soient si l'on
veut maintenant consulter dans votre
idée une intégrale un pas le conseil
économique et social mouloud a fait qui
part en parenthèse sur et élargit aussi
aux questions environnementales tout à
fait et puisque ça c'est peut-être ce
jeudi à peu près l'obligatoire
aujourd'hui mais il serait quelque chose
à côté
quoique le conseil économique et social
aurait loisir de consulter alors pour le
coup s qualité mais pas en tant que
l'exemple des du travail dominical
c'est vraiment le sujet où on peut faire
débattre comme ça a été le cas les
organisations patronales syndicales les
mouvements associatifs sportifs
culturels et autres et les réflexions
entre temps déjà suffisamment élaborées
qu'on les soumette con qu'on les teste
auprès des mouvements philosophiques et
religieux pour voir quel est leur point
de vue et d'apporter ces éléments au
débat pour le les responsables
législatif les deux assemblées et pour
le pouvoir exécutif est ce qu'il faut
pour introduire les conclusions de votre
rapport est modifié donc le consécutif
où de nouvelles lois pour
avec l'organisation du conseil d'alors
et social il y à une modification de la
constitution qui introduit d'ailleurs un
pouvoir nouveau vis-à-vis du conseil
économique et social ces le droit de
pétition droit nouveau dans le la
constitution française et
loi organique qui touche à la
composition et au fonctionnement du cns
donc on aura l'occasion lorsque tous ces
textes viendront devant le parlement
évidemment de remettre ça au goût du
jour ça va être un débat important
un débat important merci dominique jean
chertier en tout cas je rappelle que
vous êtes président du pôle emploi est
donc en charge de un secteur extrêmement
sensible dans la vie d'aujourd'hui dans
la crise d'aujourd'hui en même temps
auteur donc d'un rapport au président de
la république sur la réforme
la future réforme du conseil économique
et social qui deviendrait conseil
économique social et environnemental
environnementale
merci dominique jean chertier si michel
foucher bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes l'auteur aux
éditions odile jacob d'un petit libre
fort riche et fort intéressant qui
s'intitule l'europe et l'avenir du monde
alors comme nous sommes en pleine
préparation des élections européennes
nous allons parler d'europe - du scrutin
lui même que d'un certaines des
composantes de cette union européenne
dont on voit bien qu'elle fait l'objet
d'un désamour
dans beaucoup d'opinions notamment dans
l'opinion française qui avait été au
contraire à la tête de l'ambition
européenne et qui se trouve aujourd'hui
vraiment on ne peut plus sceptiques et
peut-être est-ce faute d'ailleurs de
bien connaître les mécanismes de
l'europe elle-même ce à quoi elle sert
et c'est ce que je voudrais commencer
par vous demander michel foucher qui est
à la fois géographe diplomates etc qui
voyait ça avec eux ils ont un point de
vue assez distant et c'est de nous dire
en quoi le parlement européen est une
institution voilà intéressante 9
démocratique
utile ou l' inverse parce que même un
certain nombre de ceux qui sont
candidats décrit aussi le rôle du
parlement européen alors comment comment
voyez vous les choses d'une institution
à la fois très utile parce qu'alain
pouvoir législatif une institution
démocratique au même titre qu'un
parlement national
c'est une institution qui est élu au
suffrage universel depuis maintenant 30
ans et à l'époque le taux de
participation avait été de 63 % et il
est vrai qu'on a baissé en 2004 le taux
moyen dans l'union était de 44 la france
étant toujours un peu au dessus
d'ailleurs c'est plutôt les nouveaux
membres qui ont tendance à moins voter
c'est une institution qui est assez
méconnu dans certains pays en
particulier en france là je fais une
critique générale il ya quatorze députés
européens qui ont quitté leur mandat
entre 2004 et 2009 députés français
européens eurodéputés c'est à dire trois
fois plus que les allemands ou les
britanniques
donc ce n'est pas une institution qui
est suffisamment investi par les
responsables politiques français
d'autant plus en france on a cette
spécificité vous connaissez très bien
qui est le cumul des mandats et qui pose
un problème
cela dit c'est qu'il faut ajouter
d'ailleurs le fait que les parties en
voit souvent à strasbourg un des lieux
un des sièges du parlement européen des
politiques parfois pour les mettre à
l'écart parfois parce qu'on ne sait pas
trop ses terres face à lyon à l'écart
les meilleurs ça n'est pas forcément là
car les meilleurs dans les listes
actuelles les vrais spécialistes alors
c'est un c'est un parlement qui a de
plus en plus de pouvoir même sans
attendre l'éventuel nouveau traité de
lisbonne
d'ores et déjà il a
il est temps qu décision avec le conseil
européen c'est à dire les chefs d'état
de gouvernement qui est l'exécutif de
l'union européenne pour à peu près 30%
des décisions législatives c'est à dire
les directives et les règlements passe
par le parlement européen le parlement
européen en ce moment
deuxième point un contrôle sur le budget
la partie non obligatoire des dépenses
avec lisbonne il aura l'ensemble du
budget on va revenir à ce qui va changer
et donner quelques points illustration
ses pouvoirs mais je voudrais juste
revenir sur un point que vous avez
évoquées pour rester d'un mot sur
l'euroscepticisme bon en france on voit
bien quels en sont les composantes mais
pourquoi est l'abstention est elle plus
forte chez les nouveaux membres
parce que les pays qui viennent
d'intégrer l'union a priori sont ceux
qui en profitent le plus concrètement
parce que l'europe a un impact immédiat
visible positif pourquoi est-ce cette
distance je pense que il estime que
d'abord on verra pour la pologne qui est
une situation assez particulière ou leur
optimisme est absolument généralisée
notamment dans les campagnes parce que
les changements se voit le innus tout à
fait frappant même quand on sort de
varsovie baisse d'enthousiasmé bon un
peu comme au portugal autrefois il y
avait des drapeaux européens
bien entendu un monde en espagne bon
mais en slovaquie en roumanie
on estime qu'on s'est déjà exprimé à
plusieurs reprises sur l'adhésion et
qu'il ya ça va de soi si vous voulez
donc ya pas cette conscience politique
d'une citoyenneté européenne
je crois que c'est lié en particulier
aux fêtes mais il faudrait de vérifier
dans le détail mais je le dis souvent 91
en 2004 six des dix états qui ont adhéré
n'avait pas d'existence étatiques en
1991 donc pour eux c'est comme l'otan
est dont l'union c'est d'abord une
garantie de souveraineté une fois que
cet acquis 2004 2007 pour bulgarie
roumanie
on estime que c'est pas forcément
nécessaire d'exprimer une nouvelle fois
une adhésion qui qui va de soi dans le
cas des pays fondateurs je crois que bon
bah le rêve est devenu réalité la
réalité est positive sur la longue durée
mais j'irai la réalité ne fait plus
rêver mais il ya une assimilation
totalement fausse entre europe et
mondialisation la mondialisation et s
étant censé être responsable de tous nos
maux l'europe et
un refus en france en particulier parce
que je pense qu'il ya une posture
française spécifique et un refus de se
considérer comme étant un acteur de ce
qu'on appelle la mondialisation
c'est-à-dire au fonds de développement
d'activités économiques par les firmes
en temps réel à l'échelle globale
il ya un refus d'assumer cette réalité
alors que c'est quand même une des bases
c'est pas la première mais c'est une des
bases de la prospérité relative
actuellement en fin de la prospérité
européenne et notre rôle dans le monde
alors revenons au parlement européen
donc il ya donc un avant et un après
lisbonne avant lisbonne dont vous disiez
le parlement européen joue déjà un rôle
concrètement sur trois chapitres et il
en est à 40 de plus le paradoxe est que
ces domaines existants touche déjà la
vie quotidienne à tous les français des
français des italiens disent que ça soit
la protection des consommateurs le
contrôle en matière d'émission de
produits chimiques ou la discrimination
ou le programme erasmus déjà et avec le
traité de lisbonne qui sera votée par
les irlandais je pense l'ensemble du
budget sera sous le contrôle du
parlement européen y compris la
politique agricole commune qu'elle
deuxième budget et la politique
régionale tels premier but j'ai
maintenant donc ça c'est très important
ça sera encore décision avec le conseil
deuxièmement il y aura 40 domaine
supplémentaires qui vont être ajoutés
aux 33 existants donc un rôle législatif
de plus en plus important ce qui veut
dire une négociation un troll et les
états est en quelque sorte les députés
européens
et puis il y aura l'élection du
président de la commission en fonction
du résultat des mesures actuellement le
parlement un pouvoir d'investiture du
président de la commission d'investiture
de la commission d'ailleurs il l'a
exercé à plusieurs reprises pour recaler
certains commissaires et il a même un
pouvoir la majorité des deux tiers de
censure de la commission ce qu'il avait
fait avec la commission de jacques
santer donc ça veut dire simplement que
le l'inflexion du vote le point de
savoir si les droites auront
une majorité absolue au contraire une
majorité relative voir une majorité très
relative est évidemment extrêmement
important et fondamental parce que
j'irai bon aller voter au parlement
c'est un acte civique
c'est un acte de citoyenneté européenne
ne peut pas à la fois critique et un
soi-disant déficit démocratique et
s'abstenir d'aller voter quand on a
l'occasion de faire acte de citoyenneté
européenne la citoyenneté c'est pas
seulement circuler sans passeport de
strasbourg à kehl c'est un acte
politique parce qu'il ya des gauches il
ya des droites il ya des libéraux qui
sont un peu des centristes il ya quand
même des différences de programme assez
nette et puis il ya un élément
d'influencé nationale il est évident que
si on a des eurodéputés françaises
solides actifs en initiatives dans les
commissions dans les présidences de
commission et on est souvent sous
représentée par rapport aux allemands
qui sont extraordinairement actifs et
ils sont évidemment plus nombreux que
nous donc on a une influence plus grande
c'est à dire que là on a l'occasion
justement de corriger ce qui est dénoncé
quotidiennement d'ailleurs un des
paradoxes de l'opinion c'est à dire
qu'on sait que ça influence notre vie
quotidienne
mais on se désintéresse des élections
qui vont déterminer cette vie
quotidienne à travers ses revenus de
décisions dont 4 à 6 et n'est pas
passive elle se vit activement mais
justement une des caractéristiques du
parlement européen parce que nous on
voit les choses très tranchées droite
gauche contre sarkozy et c'est avec des
lignes de frontières qui sont étanches
et quiconque les franchit et tout de
suite c'est parlement européen la règle
du jeu est un peu différente malgré tout
même s'il ya une droite il ya une gauche
béria et il ya des extrêmes c'est un peu
là on est dans une phase de transition
je crois que c'est la première élection
nous cette question des clivages
politiques au parlement européen
à l'image des clivages dans l'épargné
parlements nationaux se pose un peu
comme une sorte de revendications pour
les partis qui ont quelquefois du mal à
marquer une différence entre ce qui
serait une action européenne de gauche
une action européenne de droite
je crois que c'est lié évidemment à
l'histoire la construction européenne
qui est fondamentalement
dans les années 45 50 un compromis
politique historique même entre eux en
gros les démocrates-chrétiens et les
sociaux-démocrates riz etc ça ce qui a
permis contre les souverainistes et les
communistes de d'avancer de faire
quelques coups de force finalement
minorité agissante et d'imposer au fond
des éléments fédéraux comme la monnaie
ou des éléments intergouvernementaux
nombreux donc il y a en même temps une
souplesse et la capacité de former des
coalitions
selon les sujets ne serait ce que pour
exister face aux représentants des états
et à la commission parce que pour peser
le parlement doit faire corps et
quelquefois de la gauche et la droite
doivent s'associer dans des démarches
pour peser sur la commission et en même
temps et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je
trouve tout à fait anormal mais je parle
en tant que citoyen français et européen
qu'on nous dise déjà qu'elle est le
résultat des courses c'est à dire que
l'actuel président de la commission nous
dit-on quoique sera le vote sera déjà en
place alors je sais bien que les
contradictions chez sociaux démocrates
notamment en espagne
c'est tout à fait anormal c'est comme si
on avait dit aux américains
vous votez ce que vous voulez vous voter
démocrate mais le président bush sera
toujours en place j'exagère un peu en
disant ça mais là il ya un peu un déni
de démocratie et d'ailleurs il se peut
que le parlement qui sortira des urnes
entre le 4 et le 7 juin est un avis
différent sur ce qui a été déjà décidée
là il est vrai déni de démocratie
c'était le louis ce qu'on appelle la
solidarité ibérique
muni d'un spagnol et le premier josé
socratès portugais ont décidé qu'ils
voteraient pour barroso qu'il candidats
des droits qui ont agi en agit au
parlement à la fois à titre national et
en même temps quelques fois on a besoin
pour faire valoir les rôles le rôle du
parlement qui est un rôle croissant
on a besoin d'accords gauche droite
alors c'est vrai que le champ politique
n'obéit pas tout à fait aux mêmes règles
que le champ politique national
alors c'est une des questions que vous
posez dans votre dans votre livre
l'europe et l'avenir du monde où vous
posez la question de savoir s'il existe
face au reste du monde justement des
intérêts européens quels sont-ils ce
qu'ils sont perceptibles
est ce qu'ils se disent qu'ils sont
portés par les dirigeants politiques
européens où est ce que les dirigeants
politiques européens négligent l'idée
qu'il puisse y avoir des intérêts
européens se cantonne à l'agrégation à
la gestion de leurs intérêts nationaux
c'est la grande question de l'europe au
fond oui parce que je j'ai été frappé
par le fait que dans les premiers
documents vous savez le document sur la
stratégie de sécurité de solana en
décembre 2003 le mot intérêts aupérin
n'apparaît pratiquement jamais il
apparaît deux fois à propos de la bonne
gouvernance des pays voisins c'est
l'europe europe orientale méditerranée
etc
et je sais que dans la rédaction de ce
texte certains diplomates britanniques
en particulier ont pris bien soin de
gommer ce terme pour ne parler que de
priorité comme si on avait du mal à
exister politiquement jeu politiquement
par rapport à washington il a quand même
une espèce d'inhibition permanente
solana a été d'abord secrétaire général
de l'otan il ya une difficulté à
construire est donc une des façons de
s'en sortir
me semble-t-il c'est de lister quelques
intérêts communs européens par exemple
celui de la régulation maintenant dans
le domaine des institutions et
financière avec un système de
supervision
ceci a été pensé d'abord entre européens
avant d'être vendus aux américains et
aux chinois dans le cadre du g20
ça c'est un premier intérêt certainement
rester à l'avant-garde en matière
d'environnement
je dirais il ya un autre intérêt c'est
d'agir sur les crises autant que
possible en essayant de faire prévaloir
des solutions plus politique et
diplomatique que des solutions
militaires
là on a une question d'existence même
des sens même de l'union européenne
fondée sur le compromis et la paix on a
intérêt à promouvoir ce modèle de de
compromis qui qui commence à intéresser
moi je vais souvent en afrique pour
l'union africaine gim est encore cette
semaine bien ce que nous faisons
intéresse quand il ya des problèmes on a
la voix de la guerre du conflit du
blocage de la fermeture de la frontière
ou de la discussion
et je crois que là il ya un laboratoire
ce que nous faisons entre nous entre la
france l'allemagne ce terreur et je veux
pas dire exportable mais peut servir de
point de départ pour gérer certains
problèmes mais le monde ne fonctionne
pas comme nous un des grands problèmes
de ses intérêts
stratégique européen à long terme c'est
celui qui a été d'ailleurs annoncé par
nicolas sarkozy récemment dans son
discours de nîmes c'est l'idée d'une
frontière
c'est l'idée que l'europe doit se doter
d'une frontière alors dans son esprit
c'est pour la borne et à la grèce et
pour donc ne pas laisser entrer la
turquie mais en même temps c'est vrai
qu'en termes d'opinion le problème
d'avoir un territoire défini aide à la
manifestation de allahou la prise de
conscience de l'identité mais en même
temps d'autres pays où d'autres sont
partisans au contraire de ce que le
président ne parle de la turquie mais il
ne dit rien de l'ukraine où d'autres
pays donc son sont sa démonstration
n'est n'est pas n'est pas achevée en
quelque sorte c'est vrai que c'est une
question qui est compliqué d'abord il ya
plusieurs types de frontières un
emmanuel kant parlait dans le champ
scientifique de la différence entre la
limite et la borne la limite suppose que
l'autre existe on le reconnaît turque
dans l'union en dehors de l'union mais
toujours là de toute façon donc il faut
qu'on ait une politique turque quelle
que soit la forme institutionnelle la
même chose pour la russie ce à ce moment
là bornes c'est une façon de mettre une
barrière une forteresse autour d'un
ensemble géopolitique donc moi je suis
en faveur d'une réflexion sur les
limites
je pense que nous deux nous avons besoin
de limites les citoyens ont besoin
là aussi c'est quand de repères dans le
temps et dans l'espace dans le temps
c'est la saga de la construction
hautaine la longue durée et sur la
longue durée moi je soutiens qu'on est
du bon côté de l'histoire
ce qui s'est passé depuis vingt ans à
l'exception d un fair use the slave
c'est quand même extraordinairement
positif mais on a besoin de repères dans
l'espace et on peut avoir une
consolidation à 27 28
et puis des formules qui vont du statut
avancé à la marocaine à des états
associés qu'on pourrait proposer à la
turquie ou à l'ukraine des accords dire
il faut faire un peu à la carte mais la
stratégie reste la même c'est
l'européanisation à la stabilisation de
nos confins suis vieille histoire
à condition d'arriver à convaincre les
opinions et d'arrivée
et puisque nous sommes dans des
processus exclusivement démocratique
d'arriver à entraîner les uns et les
autres là où la qualité n'ont pas
tellement du leadership et de
l'énonciation des enjeux ce qui nous
manque aujourd'hui c'est quelquefois je
dirais des adresses assez solennelle de
responsable politique éminent en disant
voilà les grands enjeux voilà nous
sommes en 2009 voilà nous nous venons
depuis 20 ans et voilà les perspectives
voilà la route
saucisse amon alice fait défaut parce
qu'on est trop dans le court terme et on
perd le sens de l'histoire à sion perd
le sens de l'histoire
on perd la mémoire y compris de ce qu'on
a réussi et quelquefois quand on ne sait
pas comment agir pour l'avenir
eh bien je crois que l'histoire est un
trésor d'options ça nous aide en disant
tiens on a essayé ça ça n'a pas marché
donc moi je plaide pour une vision de la
construction peine sur la longue durée
sur la longue durée
c'est positif alors c'est cette vision
sur la longue durée qui vous donne au
fond qui fondent au fond votre optimisme
pour l'avenir merci à michel foucher
dans votre livre s'intitule l'europe et
l'avenir du monde c'est édité aux
éditions odile jacob c'est un petit
livre qui se lit très facilement et qui
peut être utile peut être avant d'aller
voter ou en tout cas pour justifier que
l'on que l'on aille voter merci en tout
cas et si vous souhaitez retrouver les
réponses
et de michel foucher et les indications
sur le contenu de son livre
rendez vous à tout moment sur
publicsenat.fr